it was a star on every road it traveled
and Mercedes was keen to mention that in
its advertising on the 280e the stars
shine from the front the back and all
around the world the top-of-the-line
model was known to insiders as the w114
and in Germany as the stroke ate for the
year of its launch 1968 the series
reached its zenith in 1972 with a to 80s
a Dan most of the to 80s had a
four-cylinder engine under the hood they
were aimed at customers who felt they
were not quite ready for the s-class
starting in the early 1970s the two
ladies numbered among the fastest sedans
on German roads a newly developed 2.8
liter 6-cylinder engine gave the sedan a
for the time impressive 185 horsepower
and broke the key 200 kilometer an hour
mark Mercedes marketed the W 114 and 115
series as the new generation models and
in fact they were thoroughly new with a
newly engineered chassis an emphasis on
quality durability and a high passive
safety the gasoline and diesel offerings
range from a decidedly plotting 54
horsepower up to the sporting 185
horsepower six-cylinder gasoline engine
but to 80s were bestsellers with nearly
two million units sold in about seven
years almost as many as all the post-war
Mercedes passenger cars before it put
together an old PR film explains that
all mercedes-benz cars are built on the
same principle crumple zones that yield
on impact with a rigid safety zone in
the middle the passenger compartment
part of the energy from a front-end
collision is absorbed by the front
section up to a given strength of impact
the passenger compartment remains stable
stubby
deadlight the same applies in a rear-end
collision the impact crushes the rear
end while the safety zone remains
functional the passenger compartments
doors can still be opened
the mercedes-benz steering column had
four safety features the steering gear
was just behind the front axle and the
column telescoped so it wouldn't push
into the passenger compartment itself
any collision a generous padded hug with
an impact absorber installed right below
catches the driver and cushions to blow
so the 280s occupants could rest assured
they were well protected and in this
model nicely pampered with luxury
appointments including real leather
upholstery and air conditioning but then
as now all this safety of luxury had its
price
you
this is August vehement notes that
what's special about this particular car
was the combination of performance and
features it was in most respects
outfitted like an s-class with genuine
leather air conditioning electric
windows and a sunroof every feature
available at that time this was no Cushi
status symbol for the senior citizen
Rhee the 280 ease engine performance
could hold its own with any sports car
of the 70s the sedan moved from 0 to 100
km/h in 9 seconds with a top speed of
200 km/h
but the six-cylinder guzzled 14 liters
of gas for every hundred kilometers a
newly designed straight six-cylinder
with dual overhead camshafts was the
biggest engine made for the series it
was powerful and achieved rpms rather
unusual for Mercedes the engine was also
used in the sporty s l and s classes
the w114 was a common sight on german
roads well into the 1990s
Koen Texas Markos demon says the car was
one of Mercedes most popular and yet on
closer inspection it proves to be an
exceptionally fine model that still
draws appreciative looks on the streets
that disdained any other benz driver
might see does not seem to apply to this
car auntie patty I'm Ben's father and a
regular Comte becomes with an orderly's
today a 280 in good condition can go for
upwards of 14,000 euros one with lots of
extras like this one would fetch
considerably more